Y, por fin, tras muchos tiras y aflojas, el
Brexit se hizo de una vez por todas realidad.
Un proyecto, una misión, un deseo que parecía
algo tan improbable como descabellado hoy
ya es un hecho. Desde comienzos del 2021,
el Reino Unido camina ya en solitario por
los truculentos caminos de la agenda política
y económica mundial.
La antigua potencia dominante del mundo se
enfrenta ahora a un nuevo futuro incierto
y repleto de dificultades.
Por ejemplo, para que os hagáis una idea,
la Comisión Europea ha estimado que el Brexit
le supondrá a la economía británica más
de 40 mil millones de libras por año. Unos
56.000 millones de dólares.
Por su parte, la Oficina de Responsabilidad
Presupuestaria del propio Reino Unido apunta
a una caída en la productividad de casi el
4% y a niveles de inflación más altos.
Los motivos que explican todas estas previsiones
tienen que ver con la salida del Reino Unido
del proyecto europeo de integración económica,
comercial y política. Fijaos.
(Aunque el acuerdo comercial alcanzado entre
el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea a finales
del 2020 suprimió la posibilidad de establecer
aranceles comerciales, no frenó los procedimientos
aduaneros que dificultan el comercio. Es decir,
los empresarios británicos se enfrentan ahora
a un montón de papeles, inspecciones y burocracia
de todo tipo en sus flujos comerciales hacia
el viejo continente. Hablamos de cosas como
los controles de salud, los controles de seguridad
o la liquidación de impuestos en aduanas.)
Y, ojo, porque no es un asunto menor. Cada
año el Reino Unido exporta a la Unión Europea
en bienes y servicios unos 400 mil millones
de dólares.
En esta línea, una encuesta de la Make UK
encontró que casi tres cuartas partes de
las empresas han experimentado retrasos en
el traslado de mercancías con la Unión Europea
durante los últimos meses.
Incluso la lucrativa industria financiera
de la City de Londres ha sufrido un buen golpe.
Y de hecho, como anécdota podemos decir que
Amsterdam ha desplazado ya a Londres como
el mercado principal de acciones de empresas
europeas.
(“Ámsterdam supera a Londres como el principal
centro de negociación de acciones de Europa.
La salida del Reino Unido de la UE provoca
un cambio en la negociación de acciones y
derivados. FT)
Ahora bien, un momento, ¿quiere decir todo
esto que el Brexit es una idea estructuralmente
mala? ¿Qué está condenada a empobrecer
irremediablemente a los británicos? ¿En
qué posición se encuentra exactamente el
Reino Unido? ¿Qué planteamiento tienen hoy
por hoy en Downing Street para enfrentarse
a esta situación?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Estamos a las puertas del renacer de la
grandeza británica o al borde de su declive
final?
Atentos.
(¿SEGURO QUE TODOS LOS CAMINOS PARECEN MALOS?)
Queridos amigos, amigas, en esta ocasión
no os voy a hablar del relativamente éxito
que el Reino Unido ha tenido respecto a la
Unión Europea a la hora de gestionar la vacunación
contra la Covid-19.
Lo que nos interesa en este vídeo es mirar
hacia adelante.
Y la primera pregunta que tenemos que responder
y tener clara es, exactamente ¿qué papel
juega el Reino Unido en la economía mundial?
Vale, lo sé, estoy seguro de que todos conocéis
el peso que tiene la City de Londres y la
industria financiera británica. Hablamos
de una de las dos grandes capitales de las
finanzas mundiales.
Para que os hagáis una idea tan solo los
servicios financieros contribuyen con casi
200 mil millones de dólares al PIB del Reino
Unido. Más del 11% de todas las empresas
cotizadas del mundo, cotizan en la bolsa de
Londres.
Pero, un momento, porque esa no es ni mucho
menos su única fortaleza.
Aunque te pueda parecer sorprendente y suela
pasar desapercibido, el Reino Unido sigue
siendo una de las grandes economías mundiales.
Hablamos de la quinta mayor economía del
mundo, tan sólo por detrás de Estados Unidos,
China, Japón y Alemania. Y también del quinto
mayor exportador de bienes y servicios.
(Y no solo eso. El peso de la inversión extranjera
directa, esto es lo que se invierte por ejemplo
en fábricas, inmuebles y empresas, en la
economía británica es mucho mayor que en
casos como el de Alemania o Francia.
Por otro lado, Reino Unido ocupa la cuarta
posición en el ranking de innovación global,
es el 3º mayor destino mundial para la inversión
en tecnología y también es el 3º país
del mundo con mayor número de unicornios.)
Sí, lo habéis escuchado.
Se suele pasar por alto, pero el Reino Unido
no solo es una potencia financiera, también
es una potencia tecnológica. Sobre todo si
lo comparamos con el resto de Europa. Los
británicos construyen más satélites y atraen
más inversión digital que cualquier otro
país europeo.
(Y no se trata solo del peso económico. Desde
el punto de vista de la seguridad el Reino
Unido tiene el segundo mayor presupuesto militar
de la OTAN y el mayor de toda Europa. Tiene
la mayor capacidad para operar a nivel mundial
del viejo continente y sus agencias de inteligencia
ocupan los primeros puestos mundiales.
Y luego está el conocido como poder blando.
Este país es el segundo destino favorito
para los estudiantes extranjeros tras Estados
Unidos. De hecho 1 de cada 4 países de todo
el mundo tiene un jefe de estado o de gobierno
que estudió en el Reino Unido.)
1 de cada 4. Eso, amigos, se llama simple
y llanamente influencia. Y todo eso por no
hablar del alcance global de la Premier, la
BBC, los colegios británicos o la música.
Es decir, en otras palabras lo miremos por
dónde lo miremos el Reino Unido sigue siendo
uno de los países más importantes e influyentes
de todo el planeta.
Y lo que es aún más, los británicos quieren
seguir teniendo protagonismo en la agenda
internacional.
Pero, ahora bien, es evidente que su situación
ha cambiado. Estar fuera de la Unión Europea
supone tener que volver a construir una política
exterior, una política comercial e, incluso,
una política de seguridad propia.
(“Después de haber dejado la Unión Europea,
el Reino Unido ha comenzado un nuevo capítulo
en nuestra historia. Estamos abiertos al mundo”.
Boris Johnson)
Queridos amigos, amigas, esto que vamos a
ver a continuación es el planteamiento, la
estrategia, la política con la que el gobierno
birtánico quiere a maximizar y consolidar
su papel a nivel mundial.
Esta es la receta, la fórmula con la quieren
superar el Brexit y a Europa.
Atentos.
(LA CONQUISTA DE ORIENTE)
Además del acuerdo de comercio y cooperación
firmado con la Unión Europea para evitar
los temidos aranceles, entre comienzos del
2019 y el 2021, el gobierno británico ha
firmado ya acuerdos comerciales con 66 países
de fuera de la Unión Europea.
(El objetivo que se han fijado en Londres
es que para finales del 2020 el país tenga
acuerdos comerciales en vigor con países
que representen al menos el 80% del comercio
birtánico. En cualquier caso de momento han
establecido un nuevo sistema global de aranceles
para aquellas importaciones que no estén
cubiertas por un acuerdo comercial que es
más sencillo y más bajo que el de la UE.)
En total, desde el 1 de enero del 2021, casi
el 60% de todo el comercio entrará al país
libre de aranceles.Y en lo que respecta al
40% restante los tipos se sitúan de media
por debajo de la convención internacional.
No es un mal comienzo.
No obstante, la gran apuesta británica, hoy
por hoy pasa por 3 campos de juego principales:
Estados Unidos, el área Canzuk y sobre todo
la reconquista de Oriente.
Si os parece, empecemos por el principio.
(Estados Unidos es el mayor socio comercial
y el mayor inversor en el país. Por eso,
una de las prioridades absolutas que Londres
se ha fijado es lograr un Tratado de Libre
Comercio con la gran potencia norteamericano.
Eso podría reforzar el papel del Reino Unido
cómo el punto de conexión natural entre
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea al tiempo
que mejoraría el acceso de las empresas británicas
a un mercado de cientos y cientos de miles
de millones de dólares)
Y esto, esto amigos, es algo que parece mucho
más fácil de lograr que un acuerdo de libre
comercio entre Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea. Es decir, que aquí el Brexit podría
suponer un claro viento a favor.
Luego, por otra parte y tal como ya os contamos
en un pasado vídeo, en Londres ha cobrado
mucha fuerza la idea de reforzar la unión
Canzuk, la integración económica del país
con Canadá, Australia y Nueva Zelanda.
Con estos 3 países, la relación a todos
los niveles es muy buena. Y aunque parezca
un club más pequeño juntos suponen el 7%
de la economía mundial.
Pero sobre todo, el punto quizás más disruptivo
de la nueva política económica y comercial
de Londres es su apuesta decidida por reconquistar
oriente.
(En Downing Street lo tienen claro. El indopacífico
es el motor de crecimiento global. La mitad
de la población, el 40% del PIB global y
las mayores tasas de crecimiento económico
se sitúan en lo que históricamente se consideró
Oriente. Hablamos de países como Japón,
China, la India, Indonesia, Vietnam o Corea
del Sur.)
Fijaos, el comercio entre el Reino Unido y
la India se más que duplicó entre 2007 y
2019 y a comienzos del 2021 los dos países
han firmado un Asociación comercial mejorada,
un acuerdo con el que esperan volver a duplicar
el comercio mutuo para el 2030 y que además
abre la puerta a un futuro tratado de libre
comercio.
Hemos hablado de ello, por cierto, en el boletín
que cada semana enviamos a todos nuestros
Patreons. Si te animas a apoyarnos os dejamos
el enlace en la descripción.
El caso es que Londres considera el mercado
Indio como absolutamente clave.
Los dos países mantienen estrechos lazos
históricos, sociales y económicos. Y si
la economía india despega de una vez por
todas, eso podría ser un enorme viento de
cola para la economía británica.
Pero, amigos, la jugada quizás más atrevida
y sorprendente ha sido la solicitud para integrarse
en el CPTPP, el acuerdo heredero del TPP;
el acuerdo transpacífico que Trump mandó
a hacer puñetas nada más llegar a La Casa
Blanca.
Claro que el resto de países siguieron adelante
sin la potencia norteamericana, creando un
mercado de 500 millones de personas y entorno
al 14% del PIB mundial.
Hablamos de Japón, Australia, Vietnam, Singapur,
Canadá, México, Malasia, Brunei, Nueva Zelanda
y Perú. Un acuerdo al que próximamente parece
que podrían unirse Corea del Sur o Tailandia
además del Reino Unido.
Pero, vamos a ver, ¿por qué demonios el
Reino Unido quiere integrarse en un acuerdo
comercial transpacífico? ¿Qué ventaja puede
tener vincularse a países tan distantes?
Fijaos.
(Más allá del acceso a 500 millones de consumidores,
integrarse en este acuerdo metería de lleno
al Reino Unido en el marco diplomático y
sobre todo, muy importante, en el marco regulatorio,
por ejemplo, en lo que concierne a los servicios
y el entorno digital, dos de los puntos fuertes
de la economía británica.
Es decir, para entendernos, integrarse en
este tipo de acuerdos, le permitirá al Reino
Unido adaptarse más fácilmente y también
contribuir al desarrollo del marco regulatorio
de algunos de los mercados con mayor potencial
económico de todo el mundo.)
Y así, de esta forma mirando directamente
a Estados Unidos, al Canzuk y sobre todo a
Oriente es como el gobierno británico de
Boris Johnson quiere convertir al Reino Unido
en el operador europeo de referencia en el
comercio mundial. Esta es la gran apuesta
con la que trabaja el gobierno británico
y con la que esperan rentabilizar el Brexit.
Además dan por hecho que poco a poco la mayoría
de las dificultades que han surgido en el
comercio con la Unión Europea irán limándose
o desapareciendo. Y que por tanto los costes
de la salida se reducirán progresivamente.
Pero amigos, el proyecto de Johnson no se
circunscribe exclusivamente al campo comercial.
Si hablamos de aspirar a mantener un rol de
potencia en el mundo, entonces tenemos que
hablar también de qué ocurre con el campo
militar.
Y eso es algo que en Londres no han olvidado.
Atentos.
(¿El REGRESO DE LA ROYAL NAVY?)
Hubo un día en el que la Royal Navy fue dueña
y señora de los mares del mundo. La punta
de lanza, el elemento indispensable, la gran
referencia del mayor imperio que jamás el
mundo haya conocido.
Sin embargo, eso es algo que queda para los
libros de historia.
(Lo cierto es que las últimas dos décadas
no han sido precisamente buenas para las Fuerzas
Armadas británicas, especialmente para Royal
Navy.
La pérdida de buena parte de sus capacidades
anfibias, de la aviación embarcada y de un
buen número de barcos supusieron un declive
sin precedentes. Por ejemplo, si en 1991 la
marina británica contaba con 34 fragatas
y 17 más en diferentes fases de producción,
en 2020 apenas contaba con 13.)
La situación era tal, que en 2010 el gobierno
retiró del servicio los harriers de la marina,
quedándose por tanto sin ala embarcada y
en 2018 ante la falta de presupuesto vendieron
a Brasil el HMS Ocean, uno de sus buques para
despliegues anfibios más importantes.
Sin embargo, ahora la situación puede ser
completamente diferente.
La llegada de los nuevos portaaviones clase
Queen Elizabeth, los nuevos cazas embarcados
F-35, la construcción de nuevas fragatas,
los nuevos submarinos de ataque Astute
y los nuevos planes de submarinos estratégicos,
el proyecto Successor, el programa militar
más caro de la historia del Reino Unido,
parecen mostrar el regreso de buenos tiempos
para la Royal Navy.
Pero, amigos, amigas, sobre todo lo que ha
cambiado es la voluntad política.
( "Proteger a nuestro pueblo, nuestra patria
y nuestra democracia es el primer deber de
cualquier gobierno, por lo que he comenzado
el mayor programa de inversión en defensa
desde el final de la Guerra Fría. Esto demostrará
a nuestros aliados, en Europa y más allá,
que siempre pueden contar con el Reino Unido
cuando realmente importa". Boris Johnson)
El gobierno birtánico ha anunciado un incremento
sustancial del gasto militar y un nuevo plan
adicional de inversión y modernización de
las Fuerzas Armadas de más de 34.000 millones
de dólares para los próximos 4 años, plan
al que hay que sumar los que ya estaban en
marcha.
En total hablamos de una cifra que puede superar
los 50.000 millones en 4 o 5 años.
Supone, con mucha diferencia, la mayor inversión
en las Fuerzas Armadas desde el final de la
guerra fría.
Además, de esta cifra una buena parte irá
a parar a programas de alta tecnología y
también a la creación de una nueva Fuerza
Cibernética y un nuevo Comando Espacial.
Incluso, el gobierno británico ha decidido
romper con su política nuclear: si en 2010
anunciaron una fuerte reducción de sus arsenales
de armas nucleares, ahora han tomado la decisión
contraria. El Reino Unido incrementará su
arsenal de armas nucleares hasta las 260 ojivas,
80 más que el objetivo anterior.
Pero eso no es todo.
(Para impulsar su presencia internacional,
el gobierno británico no solo apuesta por
mantener desplegado uno de sus nuevos portaaviones
en Indochina o incrementar el número de tropas
estacionadas en el extranjero, por ejemplo
para mejorar su operatividad con las de países
aliados como Australia, sino que también
está estudiando la apertura de nuevas bases
militares en el extranjero.
Se especula con la posibilidad de establecer
nuevas bases militares permanentes en Singapur,
Brunéi. Lo que sumaría a las instalaciones
que ya tiene en Baréin, Diego García o Belice.)
La idea, amigos es que el Reino Unido no solo
siga siendo un aliado prioritaria de los Estados
Unidos, sino también un país decisivo gracias
a sus capacidades de despliegue y disuasión.
Es decir, que el Reino Unido vuelva a ser
toda una potencia reconocida a nivel mundial
y una referencia comercial, financiera y también
militar.
Por así decirlo, esta es la otra del Brexit
de la que nunca se habla. Claro que está
por ver si Londres logrará salirse con la suya.
Y desde luego también hay muchos retos por
delante. No resulta tan fácil. Hablaremos
de ello en el futuro.
Pero de momento, turno para ti, ¿Qué futuros
crees que le espera al Reino Unido? ¿Creés
que los planes de Boris Johnson llegarán
a buen término? ¿Volveremos a ver a la Royal
Navy controlando los mares del mundo?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.